I woke up Monday to uh devastating news
that Paul Rubens
uh had passed away and
um you know you lose we lose people
all the time there's always hearing
about people that have died
and
um obviously
uh you you know some you know better
than others but uh it really
uh hit me that Paul was gone he didn't
tell a lot of us uh I don't think any of
us that that he was sick he's been uh
fighting I think his illness for a
number of years
and
um I
just adored this guy uh and I think
one of the um
things that people need to know is that
obviously uh the character of PeeWee was
just
mind-numbingly funny and surreal and
hilarious and original he was so funny
as
as Peewee but Paul when he was Paul
Reubens he was so quick so razor sharp
uh such a delightful person a very
sensitive guy
and
um you know I sent this out in a
tweet he would always be sending over on
anyone's birthday if he knew them even
slightly he would fill their
inbox that day with all these like silly
cartoons and memes about birthday old
Disney cartoons old weird memes about
birthday and cats falling into birthday
cakes and he would do it all day long
and uh it wasn't just me it was just
anybody that he encountered he would do
this for
and uh such a lovely way of we all just
want to feel seen or recognized and
for someone like Paul to do that for so
many people was just a gorgeous kind of
statement
that's a gorgeous statement of who he
was and uh
I have a bunch of memories but one thing
you know he came to my Christmas party
this year and he brought
I think 15 gifts all individually
wrapped and they're all silly things but
individually wrapped gifts
um
my Christmas party the year before he
brought a Peewee Chia Pet Head
so I put it out on display this last
year and Paul came and uh
uh it was did you guys see him yeah I
did he was there and uh
and you know it's hard to believe this
is what five months ago whatever
whatever it was but he was at the party
and
um he brought all these gifts so many
that Paul died on Monday
and
I came upstairs and it really hit me
hard and I walked into the area just
right next to my kitchen
and I suddenly saw it but I remembered
there were we opened up all of them but
there were so many we didn't get to two
and they're still there wrapped and I
can't do it like I cannot open them
because that feels like uh you know
finishing I don't I just want to leave
them wrapped for right now and I will
unwrap them but I want to leave them
unwrapped but then the other thing that
happened last night
which just is uh
surreal and magical
as you know Sona I'm not a computer
person right and so uh I've been trying
to get better at some guitar licks
recently and I have
this really good guitar teacher who's
been helping me out and his technique is
he sits with me for like two hours works
with me and then he sends me
these files it's videos of him
explaining once again how to do it so I
don't forget
and I'm not good at this I'm terrible at
this so I you know he sent it to me I
pressed the button to download it and it
went somewhere in my computer and I
wasn't sure where it went
so last night I start looking around in
the file part of my computer which I
never do I never do that yeah this is
not something I do and I'm looking at
like the Google Chrome and I'm looking
at this and I'm like where would this go
and then I find a big thing of files
and I'm going and I never do this and
I'm going through the whole thing of
files and seeing all these jpeg 33 this
many millibytes whatever I'm sorry
really imbuing those with personality
that they don't have I know I'm sorry I
apologize I'm seeing numbers and I'm
seeing files and some of them are
miscellaneous things we did for the
covid shows for The Late Night show
during covid some of them are during I
mean just literally just filled with
stuff and then I see this tiny tiny
little square
and it's this little person
and I S and I'm thinking that looks like
Paul
and I click on it and it's a message
from a year ago
that he sent me that I had watched at
the time and it was for my birthday year
before last so it's
you know a year and two months 14 months
ago whatever it was 15 months ago
and he just suddenly comes up on the
screen and talks to me
and I remember this message because I
loved it so much and saved it but it was
but I had forgotten
and he said he's just him talking to me
and telling me in a way
it felt like he was saying goodbye
because it was him saying you know how
much he values our friendship and I'm
not going to get into you know
details about it but it was such a I was
just stunned and it was I think six
minutes long and really funny but also
just incredibly sweet
and him talking to me
and I just I when it was done I went in
and I told my wife what I just watched
and she was she started crying and she
said oh my God good for him like he
he went out of his way
to tell people
what they meant to him yeah you know
what I mean he went out of his way to be
sweet and kind and
um you know I know he's
I don't know and and I'm sure he did
that for a lot of people and it made me
realize what a generous thing to do if
um at the you know this is just a year
ago so he knows he's not well and uh to
do that to to
uh extend yourself like that and do that
and it's such a gift because we we lose
people and we have no idea yeah how you
know and this this was a this was a nice
thing he did it sounds
crazy but it made me feel so much better
do you know what I mean it's like he
just
showed up on my computer magically and
had this nice conversation with me
um I don't know I just uh I've been
thinking about him constantly
and it felt appropriate
who's on the podcast in 2020
and again this is Paul this is not
Peewee this is Paul
and I don't know how well you guys
remember it but he's so quick and so
agile and fast and delightful I don't
remember him being pretty humble about
things you know not wanting to overstep
verbally and things like that yeah yeah
it's uh
he's I don't know not we shall not see
his like again